good morning John special day special
extra video yesterday you talked in your
video about 8 808 and terminus the Harry
Potter convention that we went to I
wanted to add to that conversation
because it was just a big deal just
before that event I picked up from
Kinkos some very nice people made for me
a hundred CDs with my music on it the
album was called songs from Hank Green's
pants terminus edition and I don't
remember anything about it except that I
ripped most of the songs directly from
my own YouTube videos so wasn't like a
really high quality enterprise or
anything we did sell every single one of
the ones that we didn't give away I
wonder if anybody still has a copy of
that or the one that I did before that
the the several songs from Hank Green's
pants which we sold in an event in
Michigan if anybody has either of those
I would like to buy them from you
because it made me realize in a new way
how much support we had from this
community and it felt so good to be
selling my music and I also kind of want
a memento to remember that day with
because it was a really big day it was
my first Harry Potter convention one of
the first times I played music in front
of people I met a bunch of people that
have still great friends with and that I
love dearly to this day and that feeling
of support I got from people buying my
stuff and also you know knowing that it
was going to help me pay bills and stuff
led directly to me creating with Alan
with stuff got dftba records you don't
always know when you're inside of a
super life-changing moment and sometimes
you do like for example right now I know
that I'm inside one of those moments
because we're gonna have a baby and
that's definitely I've heard pretty
life-changing what's very clear to me
now as a person who's adding to his
family and who has a lot of really
wonderful people in his life I love a
lot is that the things that make life
special aren't necessarily these big
great events and I've gotten to have a
lot of those and I'm very grateful for
them very unusual things happening to me
so much even that it starts to seem
normal it makes life special as the
people you love with the people who love
you and knowing that and feeling that
and helping them feel it from you
because I think all too often we forget
about that fabric that holds it all
together
just that we appreciate each other for
who we are today is Astor day August 3rd
it's a day on which we celebrate the
kinds of love that society is maybe a
little less good at celebrating
they're maybe not quite as exciting
despite the fact that it's the fabric
that holds our entire society together I
love you John I love you
not just because we've been able to do a
lot of really cool weird things together
through this project and not even
because you're a great collaborator and
partner and thinker because you're a
great brother because you're there for
me even when I'm being a jerk or when
I'm confused and angry and like not even
acting in my own best interest you want
the best things for me you're willing to
work through my issues to help me when I
need help which is all the time and I
want so much and try so hard to be the
same thing for you because I love you
not for any other reason
just that one life-changing moments
they're great whether you know you're in
them or not I think they deserve to be
looked at and enjoyed and sort of like
you know connected with and realize that
you're on a trajectory in your life and
you're moving through it and having
things happen to you that's all that's
all wonderful but achievements aren't
what life is made of I think the best
lives are made of love and I want to
thank Esther for giving us a day to
remember that John you'll see me
tomorrow for a very cool thing that I'm
excited about that we've been working on
for a long time so get ready for that
mostly if you're American though sorry
everybody else you get an extra video
this week if you're not American get
this one so sorry everyone is not
American